y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que les hacemos un recuento de las
noticias más destacadas relacionadas con
la pandemia del cob y 19 soy santiago
lópez gonzález a continuación les
presento los temas que vamos a analizar
en el programa de hoy
la noticia destacada de la semana
provino por parte de la farmacéutica
pfiezer y su aliada bayón texting que
anunciaron que su vacuna contra el kobe
19 ha demostrado tener una efectividad
cercana al 90 por ciento el anuncio fue
muy bien recibido en la comunidad médica
también en la comunidad científica y en
la comunidad internacional vamos a
analizar el alcance de este anuncio los
pasos que sigue a partir de esta
instancia en el desarrollo de esa avance
de esa vacuna y si podemos confiar en el
desarrollo de estas vacunas que han sido
desarrolladas en un tiempo récord debido
a la necesidad de tener una vacuna
contra el cubil 19 en otros temas sigue
siendo preocupante también la situación
en eeuu en donde el contagio con kobe 19
no da tregua el país ya ronda los 10
millones 600 mil casos estados como
texas ya superan el millón de casos
contados y son muy pocas las medidas
impuestas por parte de las autoridades
para mitigar el avance veremos cuál es
la situación en este país norteamericano
y también esta semana hubo noticias
destacadas en brasil en torno a la paz
kobe 19 el presidente ya y el bolsón aro
lanzó un insulto homófobo para hablar
sobre la pandemia al tiempo que volvió a
mitigar el impacto de ella en brasil
asimismo también allí se presentaron
algunas complicaciones en torno a las
investigaciones que están adelantando
allí algunas de las vacunas no han
respondido a la velocidad que estaba
previsto
vamos a ver entonces qué es lo que está
sucediendo en este país suramericano
vamos a comenzar entonces hablando de la
vacuna que como ya lo decíamos en contra
el kobe 19 que se está haciendo
desarrollada por parte de facer de una
compañía que está trabajando en
mancuerna con variante que han
demostrado tener una efectividad cercana
al 90 por ciento así lo dieron a conocer
estas dos empresas la noticia generó
todo tipo de reacciones en la comunidad
internacional pero para la comunidad
científica todavía faltan algunos
eslabones en esa cadena de producción
que permita garantizar una efectividad
un poco más alta y por eso vamos a
conversar con un experto
para poder conocer los detalles que
quedan para el desarrollo de esta vacuna
por eso conversamos con xabier sáenz
llorens él es infectólogo pediatra
también es investigador de vacunas el
jefe de invex de infectología y es
director de investigaciones clínicas y
nos atendió más temprano en la ciudad de
panamá y le preguntamos cómo recibió la
comunidad científica y médica esta
noticia que causó repercusión a nivel
internacional esto fue lo que nos dijo
uno en primer lugar
y habría que decir que la comunidad
científica aún después de dar la noticia
todavía está cautelosamente optimista
porque la información fue dada por el
objetivo de la empresa pero los datos
la protección libro
y si de la inmunidad general estado
entonces hay un bien un optimismo
cauteloso en este sentido porque hay
muchas preguntas todavía que hay que
responder
y que son importantes para saber si
estas vacunas además de segura van a ser
altamente efectivas por ejemplo no
sabemos la duración de esa inmunidad es
a ese grado esa protección del 92 por
ciento ese 92 por ciento es calculado
basado en que ellos tuvieron
aproximadamente unos 94 casos de kobe
la muestra de 40.000 voluntarios que
participaron en los estudios y se
presume que más del 90 por ciento de
estos casos de kobe ocurrieron en el
grupo control o en el grupo que no
recibió la vacuna pero no tenemos ese
detalle tampoco tenemos detalles por
ejemplo si en ese grado de protección es
para los los adultos menores de 60 años
o también para los mayores de 60 tampoco
sabemos si es para todas las etnias sino
solamente proteger por ejemplo a
población caucásica sino también a
población negra asiática latinoamericana
al sexo tanto hombre como mujer y algo
que es muy muy importante es no sabemos
si los casos de kobe que se tuvieron en
la mayoría fueron leves entonces lo
importante es que la vacuna proteja
contra los casos graves porque lo que
queremos es que se disminuya
la posibilidad de muerte y también otra
cosa que es bien importante es saber si
ellos cuantificaron los casos de kobe
que no tuvieron síntomas o sea los
asintomáticos porque eso nos pudiera dar
luces sobre la protección contra la
transmisibilidad del virus y lógicamente
pues nos podría darle un luces sobre la
inmunidad colectiva de rebaño que
pudiera inducir esta vacuna
y por último me faltan también los
correlatos de protección saber si en los
que no tuvieron kobe los anticuerpos o
la inmunidad celular fue mejor que en
los que tuvieron kobe y por último para
terminar otra cosa que es sumamente
importante es que este estudio fue
realizado en adultos entonces todavía no
tenemos ningún dato de seguridad y
eficacia por ejemplo en niños o en
mujeres embarazadas
lógicamente pues todo esto datos falta a
la hora de poder interpretar mejor esa
eficacia del 92% que se menciona en la
prensa
también le preguntamos al doctor science
y teniendo en cuenta la cautela y las
precauciones que él menciona podemos
confiar en esta vacuna que fue
desarrollada más rápido de lo normal si
lo comparamos con otras vacunas a todo
por la necesidad que hay de hacer frente
a esta pandemia a nivel mundial del
móvil 19 esto fue lo que nos dijo
no definitivamente toda la mayor parte
de la comunidad científica cree que va a
haber vacunas seguras y efectivas sin
lugar a dudas y de hecho se la fd a por
ejemplo y la ema en europa habían dicho
que con tener 50 o 60 por ciento de
efectividad ellos le ellos podían dar
autorización de emergencia estamos
hablando ahora de más de 90% o sea que
realmente es extraordinariamente alta
las cifras pendientes lógicamente de
todas las variables que yo acabo de
mencionar
y el hecho de que se haya hecho el
desarrollo y ha sido mucho más rápido
que otras vacunas también obedece a
varios factores por ejemplo estas
vacunas no partieron de cero porque en
las plataformas tecnológicas con la cual
se han desarrollado ya habían sido
ensayadas y probadas para cuando ocurrió
al izar el sars tipo 1 y cuando ocurrió
el menos que se pensaba que tenía
necesidad de esta vacuna pero ambas
epidemias de coronavirus fueron
controladas rápidamente ya que esta
vacuna realmente no han partido de cero
y aparte que se están haciendo en lo que
llamamos fases adaptativas de evaluación
en que la información fluye en tiempo
real y se pasa de una fase a otra
rápidamente y hay un gran subsidio
económico a las empresas por parte de
gobiernos por parte de fundaciones
filantrópicas etcétera nos hace mucho
más fácil el desarrollo de esta vacuna
que las vacunas tradicionales ahora otro
otro elemento importante que hay que
considerar es la logística de la cadena
porque estaba con una de facer por
ejemplo hay que mantenerla a menos menos
90 grados centígrados entonces se va a
necesitar que en nuestros países haya
una logística de guardar estas vacunas
de preservar las de garantizar la esa
temperatura en lugares urbanos y en
lugares remotos para asegurar que se
pueda vacunar a una gran cantidad de
población y que las vacunas van a ser
viables por por mantener la cadena de
frío
de ser aprobada esta vacuna una difícil
situación que se va a presentar es la
distribución algo que es muy difícil
sobre todo en américa latina debido a
que varios sistemas de salud de algunos
de los países son muy deficientes y no
tienen la capacidad de cobertura total
del territorio o también carecen de los
recursos necesarios para poder
garantizar que estas vacunas lleguen a
todos los territorios esto fue lo que
nos respondió el doctor sans
no definitivamente que va a haber
obstáculos importantes y más que está en
la cadena de frío es totalmente distinta
a la que estábamos acostumbrados con las
otras vacunas tradicionales
ya nuestros ministerios de salud de
latinoamérica lo sabían ya han
establecido conversaciones con estas
empresas para ver de qué manera se
garantizaba la cadena de frío
la empresa fisher ya ha dicho que tiene
toda una logística implementada para que
ellos no sea un obstáculo en los países
habría que ver realmente si es así y de
hecho y hay otras vacunas que han
anunciado que también pronto va a tener
resultados e incluso vacunas que no
utilizan esta plataforma de rn a
mensajeros sino que utilizan por ejemplo
vectores virales o vacunas de proteínas
que quizás no tengan esa dificultad en
cuanto a la cadena de friosa que va a
haber varias vacunas con diferentes
plataformas tecnológicas que se van a
ofrecer a todo el mundo para tratar de
garantizar que haya acceso que haya
buenos precios y que que estas estos
obstáculos estas dificultades sean
solventadas de la mejor manera posible
también le preguntamos al doctor science
que sigue en esta investigación para
desarrollar una vacuna que pasos
continúan para hacer llegar una
inoculación a los habitantes
en la fase 3 en la última fase es la
fase de en donde se determina la
eficacia protectora de la vacuna ahora
lo que queda es que la fd a la ema a la
organización mundial de la salud le den
licencia le den autorización de
emergencia y después licencia comercial
para que se pueda distribuir en todas
partes del mundo y ser aceptada por los
países así que lo que queda es poco
tiempo y de hecho ya se ha anunciado
como que a finales de este año es
probable que algunas de estas vacunas
sea la de facer la de moderna que viene
por ahí la de astrazéneca también la de
hang seng se le ofrezca a esta esta
autorización de emergencia y también
sabemos que está la vacuna rusa y varias
vacunas chinas que también están
buscando este tipo de aprobación así que
hay una gama de diferentes plataformas
de vacunas de diferentes países que
pudieran ser ofertadas y habrá que
analizarlas adecuadamente con la
información científica pública para
tomar las decisiones en cada país por
último le preguntamos al doctor science
por la vacuna rusa sputnik ve que
también esta semana anunció que tiene
una efectividad del 92 por ciento
levemente superior entonces al anuncio
hecho por facer que sabe la comunidad
internacional y científica sobre esta
vacuna desarrollada en rusia
bueno en occidente sabemos mucho menos
de la información sobre la vacuna rusa y
sobre las vacunas asiáticas aquí
realmente tenemos mucho más información
y la prensa contribuye a eso de forma
transparente desde empresas americanas o
empresas europeas
así que tenemos muy poca información
tanto de la vacuna rusa como de varias
vacunas chinas que están también en fase
3 en la medida que se tenga esa
información uno va a los países va a
decidir qué vacuna es la más efectiva la
más segura la que ofrece más garantías
la más barata y tomar decisiones basadas
en evidencia no porque lo que se quiere
realmente que haya evidencia científica
publicada para que hagamos una decisión
lo más objetiva posible de las mejores
vacunas para nuestra región
después de estos anuncios la comisión
europea firmó un contrato con la
farmacéutica pfiezer para asegurar 300
millones de dosis de vacunas que van a
ser distribuidas en todo el bloque
comunitario en el siguiente reportaje
les contamos cómo sigue avanzando la
carrera por el desarrollo de una vacuna
contra el jove y 19
una ola de esperanza es lo que desató la
noticia de facer la farmacéutica
estadounidense y su socio alemán jong
tec anunciaron que su vacuna
experimental tenían una eficacia
superior al 90 por ciento y poco después
la unión europea ya anunciaba que había
sellado un acuerdo para el suministro de
hasta 300 millones de dosis tres veces
más que las dosis preordenadas de
momento por eeuu sin embargo las compras
podrían tener lugar sólo después de que
la vacuna sea autorizada como efectiva y
segura por el regulador de medicamentos
de la unión europea se lo vas a prometer
a suyo esta es la vacuna más prometedora
hasta la fecha una vez que esté
disponible en nuestro plan es
desplegarlo rápidamente por toda europa
todos los estados miembros recibirán sus
parte al mismo tiempo en las mismas
condiciones como son doblemente
condición el anuncio del fallo ha
supuesto un sprint en la carrera por una
vacuna contra el coi 19 en efecto las
autoridades rusas han afirmado este
miércoles que la inyección sputnik 5 ha
probado ser eficaz en el 92% de los
casos aunque
expertos dijeron que los datos rusos
eran alentadores advirtieron que los
resultados sólo se basaban en un pequeño
número de voluntarios lo que no impidió
al director del instituto que desarrolló
la vacuna afirmar que las vacunaciones
masivas se extenderían por todo rusia en
las próximas semanas al igual que con
los resultados de fai si aún no está
claro cuánto tiempo duraría la inmunidad
después de tomar esta vacuna ni cuán
eficiente sería para los diferentes
grupos de edad nuestra región américa
latina' también compite en esta carrera
por una vacuna contra el cob y 19 cuba
lidera en la región con el estudio de
dos vacunas que podrían ser distribuidas
en un futuro cercano otros países han
apostado por vacunas experimentales que
son desarrolladas a nivel mundial
mientras que otros países como méxico y
brasil han realizado acuerdos con
importantes farmacéuticas para realizar
y garantizar allí y poder acceder a
algunas vacunas para sus territorios
el candidato vacunal es pues la carrera
por la vacuna contra el cob y 19 se
libra también en américa latina con cuba
a la cabeza mientras varios países
latinoamericanos aprueban vacunas
experimentales mundiales y compiten por
acuerdos de suministro con las
principales farmacéuticas la habana
tiene en camino dos vacunas propias que
entrarán en la fase 2 de ensayos
clínicos antes de final de año todos los
esfuerzos están para que en el año 2021
primer semestre se pueda disponer de una
vacuna que sea efectiva que logre el
anticuerpo que no provoque reacciones
adversas importantes y en ese esfuerzo
esta cuba también la isla caribeña que
tiene un sólido historial de vacunas
podría convertirse en un importante
proveedor para los países de la región
con sus dos candidatos vacunales
soberana 1 y su ganador favoreciendo a
las naciones vecinas que no tendrían que
depender de las vacunas occidentales
para asegurarse las dosis
puede significar muy importante estos
aportes que tendría cuba con su vacuna
para determinados grupos vulnerables en
nuestros países de la región este
viernes astrazéneca que están
produciendo méxico y argentina junto con
la universidad de oxford indicó que ha
cerrado acuerdos para suministrar más de
200 millones en sus dosis a 6 países de
américa latina'
estos acuerdos reflejan nuestro
compromiso de poner a los pacientes
primero y llevar la vacuna de manera
amplia y equitativa a millones de
personas en américa latina' de
confirmarse su seguridad y eficacia
mientras que varias naciones
latinoamericanas se están priorizando
acuerdos con los principales fabricantes
considerando vacunas en pruebas
avanzadas de china y rúsia como brasil
que continúa los estudios clínicos de la
inyección desarrollada por el
laboratorio chino sinovac
y eeuu batió su récord en número de
casos y hospitalizaciones por kobe 19
durante esta semana el país lleva varios
días registrando más de 100.000 casos de
contagio diario también alcanzó su cifra
más alta de hospitalizaciones con cerca
de 62 mil ingresos en diferentes estados
de la unión americana el país llega
también a los 10 millones 600 mil casos
y se aproxima rápida rápidamente a los
11 millones de casos confirmados de
contagio de kobe 19
cientos de automóviles ocupan el
parqueadero de un estadio de béisbol en
los ángeles conductores esperando su
turno para realizarse la prueba del 19 a
la vez que eeuu suma un nuevo récord en
contagios fuentes oficiales reportaron
más de 160.000 nuevos casos el jueves el
mayor número desde que la pandemia
comenzó los casos están incrementando en
46 de los 50 estados pero el repunte es
especialmente fuerte en chicago la
alcaldesa anunció un mes de cuarentena
preventiva y un límite de reuniones de
10 personas
conway
estamos muy lejos de donde necesitamos
estar las próximas siete semanas van a
ser cruciales cruciales para definir
cómo comenzaremos el 2021 estaremos en
una situación mejor podremos darle la
bienvenida al año nuevo como algo
ansiado y sin temor thunder with love
for the world
los hospitales están sintiendo la
presión en dakota del norte se anima a
trabajar a las enfermeras que han dado
positivo pero no tienen síntomas
mientras que en yuta han llegado a unas
31 enfermeras desde new york para ayudar
con el trabajo con cerca de 70.000
hospitalizaciones el jueves se
estableció un nuevo récord un número que
se ha duplicado en cinco semanas además
la tasa de muerte supera las mil diarias
menor que en primavera pero en aumento
el mayor experto en enfermedades
infecciosas del país ha dicho que eeuu
está en una situación muy difícil pero
tiene esperanza en la vacuna anunciada
esta semana show
si tenemos esperanza en que los que
tienen dudas acerca de la vacuna que son
escépticos vean que su eficacia es tan
alta que cambie su opinión sobre
vacunarse game change the moon i want to
get back mientras que a eeuu todavía le
falta enfrentarse a un invierno que se
aproxima ya un evento mayor el día de
acción de gracias las autoridades instan
a los estadounidenses a mantener
reuniones pequeñas y a doblar las
medidas de seguridad
vamos a conversar con cristóbal vázquez
corresponsal de france 24 en la ciudad
de washington la capital de estados
unidos para conocer más detalles de la
situación allí en este país
cristóbal gracias por estar con nosotros
y le hago dos preguntas en una cuál es
el panorama que se está viviendo en eeuu
vemos que hay un rápido avance en el
número de personas contagiadas y también
cuáles son los estados son las regiones
de este país donde se están presentando
la mayor cantidad de casos de contagio
santiago pues allí hay alarma hay
bastante preocupación hay usted el según
lo mencionaba hay más de 130.000 casos
diarios al día 240 mil muertes en eeuu y
pues la tasa de hospitalización está
creciendo esto ha hecho que muchos
estados pues tomen medidas al respecto
medidas que van como la obligación del
porte de máscaras también
recomendaciones para que la gente evite
ir de un estado al otro y así contagiar
a sus familiares viajando por el país y
evitar pues las congregaciones en
festividades y se viene el 26 de
noviembre una fecha muy importante acá
en eeuu la fecha del tec y bing y ya
anthony fauci pues está diciendo que por
favor los estadounidenses tienen que
tener en cuenta que se deben reunir en
grupos pequeños que si es posible hacer
estas reuniones afuera y que obviamente
con máscaras portando máscaras lo que
muchos analistas están diciendo santiago
es que la gente ya está cansada ya está
cansada de seguir teniendo que se pues
cumplir con estas medidas que recomienda
las autoridades y pues ven una vacuna
cercana así que están tomando más a la
ligera estas recomendaciones y pues le
voy a dar los datos de los estados que
más tienen casos de kobe de texas y
california en estados unidos superan ya
el millón de casos la florida e illinois
después están en el tercer y cuarto
puesto santiago cristóbal hace pocos
minutos también el presidente de donald
trump habló sobre cómo va a ser la
llegada de una posible vacuna a los eeuu
y cómo va a ser el proceso para
garantizar que llegue hasta el último
rincón de la unión americana y también
cuéntenos en detalle qué es lo que ha
dicho el presidente electo joe biden en
torno a este tema de la vacuna la
distribución y el plan que les está
moviendo digamos en su campaña hace unas
semanas para hacer frente a la pandemia
de kobe 19 en eeuu
si de hecho el presidente de trump se
refirió a esta emergencia de kobe que
vive eeuu desde la casa blanca es
importante resaltar que cerca de 40
funcionarios de su círculo cercano pues
han contraído el cobista pero
concretamente a lo que dijo el
presidente pues resaltó obviamente los
esfuerzos que ha hecho su oficina la
casa blanca sobre todo el préstamo la
plata que le dio a facer fueron cerca de
2 billones de dólares que el gobierno de
eeuu le dió a facer para el desarrollo
de esta vacuna una vacuna que según el
presidente de trump estará lista para la
distribución a la mayoría de los
estadounidenses en abril del próximo año
resaltó el presidente de trump que para
los trabajadores de la salud para los
trabajadores esenciales y para la gente
de la tercera edad esta vacuna podría
estar lista lo que ha dicho
fisher es que ya la vacuna está lista ya
la vacuna hay muchas dosis que ya están
almacenadas están esperando es la
aprobación de la de la fed
para empezar la distribución pero de
hecho el cdc santiago ya le dijo a los
estados que se prepararan para que el 15
de noviembre pues ya pudieran empezar a
recibir las dosis lo que dicen aquí
también en eeuu es que esas dosis tienen
retos esas vacunas tienen retos
logísticos sobre todo en temas de
temperatura que resaltar que estas
vacunas tienen que mantenerse por debajo
de los 75 grados celsius muchas gracias
cristóbal por este reporte desde la
ciudad de washington vamos a cambiar de
tema vamos a ir ahora con noticias de
suramérica desde el llamado estallido
social en octubre del 2019 en chile las
carpas que fueron instaladas en medio de
la capital santiago se han convertido ya
en parte del paisaje capitalino muchas
de ellas también se han convertido en
hogares de personas que son habitantes
de calle que buscan refugio en estas
carpas pero que tienen allí dificultad
para respetar las medidas de
bioseguridad y se han convertido
entonces en puntos de fácil y de rápido
contagio de kobe 19
la luna nos cuenta desde la capital
chilena
juan recibe su primer corte de pelo en
muchos meses el tema del aseo y lavarse
es lo que más le cuesta a este joven de
su nueva situación vivir en una carpa en
la calle una experiencia que califica
como denigrante en chile- la sucesión
del estallido social de octubre que
afectó duramente a la economía y la
pandemia ha obligado a muchas personas a
alternativas extremas
para esta red social perdí mi pega y no
puede seguir pagando más arriendo y
después nos fuimos para santiago y
llegando a perder suerte llegamos
delante de la pandemia y por situación
de trabajo y había por lo despido del
día a día entonces estaba muy difícil la
cosa hasta el día de hoy ocho meses
después sigue en la calle juan y su
pareja guillermo eligieron este lugar de
santiago centro porque había otras
carpas cercanas y por las cámaras pues
temen por su seguridad y han sufrido
ataques también de la municipalidad el
día anterior a la entrevista se llevaron
su carpa con sus documentos personales
incluido la carpa todo lo que te piden
que te votan todo todo todo todo para
ello es basura ante el aumento de carpas
este grupo de amigos decidió organizarse
hacer colectas y reunirse para preparar
paquetes con comida carpas y útiles de
aseo personal que entregan cada dos
semanas surgió porque un grupo amigos
vecinos empezamos a ir a más gente en
situación de calle más
de lo normal o no en general como si no
teníamos menos claro los sectores donde
había carpas pero eso se multiplicó en
una calle pasó de haber una carpa de 4
como que nos sentíamos un poco como de
que ellos estaban muy desvalidos
según estimaciones el número de carpas
aumentó entre 300 y 500 durante la
pandemia solo en santiago bajo techo
en el pacto no más un techo frágil y
nómada para un colectivo amenazado por
la pandemia y por la inseguridad y
olvidado por el estado
en nuestra sección en redes veamos otras
noticias destacadas esta semana aquí en
kobe 19 la semana en américa el
continente europeo superó los 300 mil de
personas fallecidas por kobe 19 esto
haciendo referencia precisamente al
rápido avance que tiene la segunda ola
de contagio en el viejo continente allí
también se registran 12 millones de
casos confirmados los países más
afectados siguen siendo francia españa
el reino unido italia y alemania
y canadá a comprar a 7.6 millones de
tests rápidos
becton dickinson contra el cob y 19 así
lo anunció el gobierno canadiense que
indicó que este tipo de test ha sido
validado por parte de las autoridades
sanitarias del país hace poco más de un
mes su dispositivo es del tamaño de un
teléfono celular y puede dar la
respuesta de diagnóstico en solamente 15
minutos la farmacéutica astrazéneca
suministrar a 216 millones de vacunas a
6 países de américa latina esto después
de que la compañía cerrará acuerdos de
distribución con países como argentina
brasil costa rica república dominicana
ecuador y méxico
y el continente americano sigue siendo
el foco de la pandemia por el alto
número de casos pese a que europa es el
continente donde más rápido se están
empezando a presentar allí nuevos casos
de kobe 19 4 países en la región eeuu
brasil argentina y colombia ya superaron
el millón de casos eeuu como ya lo
decíamos está por llegar a los 11
millones de casos pero hagamos énfasis
en la región de centroamérica que vive
una doble emergencia por cuenta de la
pandemia y por el paso del huracán eta
que ha hecho que estos países sean más
vulnerables en cuanto al incremento de
posibles casos de kobe 19 debido a que
las personas están en refugios donde es
muy difícil mantener las medidas de
bioseguridad del panorama entonces es el
siguiente
nicaragua tiene más de 5 mil 661 casos
contabilizados honduras que es uno de
los países donde cerca de un millón de
personas han sido afectadas por el
huracán está allí hay 101 mil 468 casos
reportados guatemala presenta más de 114
mil 120
y allí han pedido ayuda a la comunidad
internacional para hacer frente a las
dos situaciones el salvador tiene más de
36 mil 195 casos mientras que belice es
un país que no tuvo tantos problemas con
el paso del huracán pero registra cuatro
mil 596 casos de kobe el 19
y las autoridades sanitarias de brasil
autorizaron a reformar ya retornar los
experimentos e investigaciones que
estaban avanzando allí en este país para
desarrollar una vacuna china esto
después de que presentaran allí la
muerte de uno de los voluntarios
entonces el gobierno pues después de
garantizar que el desarrollo de la
vacuna cumplía con todos las necesidades
médicas autorizaron continuar con esta
investigación por otro lado nuevamente
hubo controversia por los anuncios
hechos por parte del presidente de ayer
bolsonaro quien ha minimizado el avance
de la pandemia de kobe 19 y la
importancia de la pandemia en este país
también hubo insultos homófobos para
referirse a la pandemia
de vida todo ahora es pandemia tenemos
que acabar con eso lo siento por todos
los que han muerto lo siento
todos vamos a morir algún día todos
vamos a morir tú vas a morir algún día
no tiene sentido intentar escapar de la
realidad
tenemos que dejar de ser un país de
mariquitas sé que estoy dando de comer a
la prensa aquí próxima empresa
y seguimos hablando de la situación en
varas y luego a lo largo de esta semana
varios anuncios a valera saccone nos
cuenta más detalles
en brasil el presidente de jair
bolsonaro ha optado por politizar el
asunto de la vacuna que tendrá que
inmunizar a los 210 millones de
habitantes de ese enorme país todo
empezaba el lunes cuando fueron
suspendidos los ensayos de una vacuna
que está siendo desarrollada por la
empresa china sinovac con un instituto
de investigación llamado butantán que
está en san paolo la razón sería la
muerte misteriosa de un paciente en un
primer momento se barajó la idea de que
pudiese haber muerto por los efectos
colaterales de esta vacuna sin embargo
el martes el presidente yer bolsonaro
publicó en sus redes sociales un texto
que fue muy criticado celebrando como
una victoria la suspensión de los
ensayos y diciendo que era otra batalla
que él ganaba todo el espectro político
crítico de esas declaraciones porque
decían que es como celebrar la muerte de
un paciente para entender lo que ha
pasado hay que remontarse a la gran
rivalidad entre bolsonaro y el
gobernador del estado de san paulo joao
doria que antiguamente era un aliado de
bolsonaro pero qué
quiere ser presidente en las próximas
elecciones entonces en estos momentos
hay una gran rivalidad entre los dos que
ha quedado patente a lo largo de toda la
pandemia porque doria fue muy firme en
implementar medidas de confinamiento al
principio de la pandemia
sin embargo bolsonaro siempre fue
negacionista y siempre quiso defender la
economía por encima de todo y se ha
pasado todos esos meses criticando
abiertamente a toreador ya que ha hecho
de la vacuna su caballo de batalla desde
el primer momento ha dicho que iba a
vacunar a todos los habitantes de san
paolo encomendó 46 millones de dosis de
vacuna y quería sacar un ratito de
rectoral de esta jugada ahora parece que
el tiro le ha salido por la culata el
presidente y jair bolsonaro porque esta
semana supimos que la persona que murió
el voluntario en realidad se suicidó
entonces su muerte no tiene nada que ver
con los ensayos y bolsonaro tuvo que
aparecer en sus redes sociales dando
marcha atrás diciendo que si la anvisa
la agencia reguladora
a prueba los medicamentos y el
ministerio de sanidad aprueban la vacuna
el autorizar a su compra mientras tanto
brasil está prácticamente en la puerta
de los 165 millones de muertos y algunos
médicos apuntan a que estamos viviendo
una segunda ola a pesar de que la
primera nunca acabó oficialmente los
datos muestran que cada vez hay menos
muertos y menos contagiados pero muchos
médicos están poniendo en entredicho los
datos oficiales dicen que en sus
hospitales están llenos que hay cada vez
más pacientes y hay que recordar que
brasil está en el medio de una campaña
electoral el domingo se celebran los
comicios locales en 5.500 ciudades y
para algunos observadores informar a la
baja sobre las víctimas del comité sería
una forma de no interrumpir los actos
electorales llegamos al final del
programa siga con nuestra programación
feliz fin de semana